hey guys a time for gamespot news update
final fantasy 13 launched on PC today
but unfortunately it's locked at 720p
and the game lacks even the most simple
graphics settings look at the settings
screen shows only gameplay options like
adjusting the difficulty in controls but
there are no graphics quality options
generally considered standard for PC
games these days the lack of controls
for texture quality post-processing
effects vsync and framerate mean that
there's little flexibility for
optimizing the game's performance for
different pcs it's all or nothing and
some mid-level pcs that meet the minimum
requirements for final fantasy 13 that
did play shadow of mordor an ultra at
over 30 frames per second cannot run the
game at a playable framerate not only is
the resolution of the game unchangeable
it's locked at 720p with no options for
different aspect ratios let alone 1080p
support amazingly though you won't have
to wait for Square Enix to make an
official patch as noted modern durante
who created a mod for dark souls that
basically fixed the game has already
released a plug-in for final fantasy 13
it brings the game's resolution up to
1080p another strange porting decision
has the escape button instantly closing
the game without warning while pressing
alt f4 brings up a confirmation window
to exit the game this is only the first
of three games on the final fantasy 13
saga that will be released for pc so the
response to these issues could have an
effect on future titles we've reached
out to square enix for comment and if we
get any updates you'll be able to find
them on gamespot com / news